Mina it is so great to talk to you again
thanks so much for your time congrats on
good Bones season eight we're finally
here
um you know it's so interesting to see
eight seasons and you guys started in
2016 and I'm just wondering like do you
ever ever drive in the neighborhood and
you're like I made that house like that
is something that I did actually
yesterday so my brother and his uh
sister-in-law their four kids just moved
back um you guys actually saw him on my
mom's care toss episode they finally
moved off from San Francisco and we were
all playing outside uh yesterday and he
was like did you do this one did you do
this one I was like and our neighbors
are there who were in season one and
still live in the house and I was like
they're actually a season one house and
these three on the block are ones we did
before the show even started and
okay like when you look at it that way
it's it's cool but it's just not
something that I think about you know
day to day so I think it's something to
be really proud about because you are
like seriously rehabilitating the
neighborhood it looks so good
um there are so many different homes
that need that help and that love and
like for you to like just dive in there
and just do what you do is awesome
um I do feel like every season really
levels up in terms of design and
approach so I'm wondering what can fans
expect from this season with the
renovations and I know there's always a
little bit of drama some catastrophic is
happening so what can we see
um I mean yeah a lot a lot of the same
as far as there's always drama things
always go wrong
um but you're so right about the design
when I look back on like my very first
house I am so glad that those pictures
don't exist anymore on Facebook because
I'm not like trained I guess I didn't go
to school for design and it's something
that I've developed over the last
oh my gosh it's like a decade and a half
now I feel old
um so a lot of the designs are we do
some really unique cool like custom
builds um with the iron Timbers boys
that are ones that I've wanted to do for
a while we've got like some secret doors
and custom furniture and cool things
like that
um so I'm excited for everyone everyone
to see yeah and let's talk about this
season it does open up with you and
Corey and I know you guys have a long
history you've been friends for years
has there ever been a time though where
you two kind of butt heads and it's far
more dramatic than what we're seeing on
TV because like for the most part I feel
like it's Shenanigans but there's always
more to meet CI right oh yes
um and Cory and I have known each other
since we were he was 11 and there's
always more I mean what you guys see is
what like 43 42 3 43 minutes of an
episode that took sometimes a year if
we've like really messed up the schedule
um and there are plenty of times where
it is more more Shenanigans than is on
camera so Corey knows how to push my
buttons I will say that for sure uh you
guys are fun though this Premiere
episode was so fun to see you like
there's like a different Dynamic I think
when we see you guys you've seen the
premiere and I haven't yeah I always get
access I don't know I don't know I get
the first episode it's really good I
think HGTV you guys got to hook her up
um yeah a lot happens behind the scenes
and sometimes those things you know they
don't get added in so is there anything
that happened this season
um that the cameras you know will not be
showing us but you wish viewers got to
see her even if because you haven't seen
this season as yet maybe something from
last season that you were noticing yeah
well I think a lot of people have
questions even since our announcement so
many questions about Mom's retirement
and you know Corey and Tad's position in
the company because it's a little
confusing because there's not time like
you don't get to see a before and after
beautiful reveal if we're talking about
everything that goes on in our lives and
we are like so dramatic so there's lots
of things but you know trying to clarify
with people like Mom Mom did retire from
the company a few years ago but she's
still part of the show and does the
landscaping and things like that and
Corey actually haven't worked for my
company for a while
um but they still have a presence on the
show so hopefully it's not too confusing
to people
um we're all still together but in
different and you know in different ways
as far as how the business is set up
yeah and I think it's interesting too
because the show is filmed across months
and we're seeing it in 40 minutes and so
you're filming like sometimes like those
asides you know after maybe two months
but like the filming is correct the
renovation so there's a lot of like
weaving together a lot of scenes yeah so
it makes a lot of sense
um you know what I do love though about
the show is that it's also very
educational it's not just for the
structure of the home though it's like
what the home can do for you and I loved
in this Premiere episode we got to see
the income unit like we got to see what
it was look like what could you know
become how how we make it when it comes
though to you know creating a specific
type of home that benefits the buyer
what are some of the things you have to
consider to set this property apart from
like a regular home like I I have to say
though that the upstairs was really well
done it's like NYC Vibes I loved it uh
so that was so fun and it was really
cool to be able to have them come back
and see it
um and I don't know I don't think it
talks much about it but that at the
couple actually reached out to us
personally because they knew we wouldn't
tear the house down and we had a very
honest conversation and I said look I
can I can spend this so I don't lose my
butt on the renovation you could
probably get more from someone else they
might tear it down
um so it was very it was amazing that
they decided to you chose me to to do
the property
um but I think the biggest thing I'm
seeing setting properties aside which I
wish it was an easier answer I wish it
was like farm sink versus you know under
amount but it's having an income
potential Suite
um and being able to if you have the
forethought and you're doing a design
even if you're not making an income
Suite now but having that thought
process in the long run so even when Mom
renovated her house she wanted a big
Loft upstairs and I said whenever you
sell this
you need this fourth bedroom or third
bedroom you really need this so we laid
out the can lights we did everything in
a way that that space had a closet it
had egress windows and you could pop a
wall up at the door and it created the
needed third bedroom for resale so I
think thinking through how you live and
want to function and if there's a way to
tie in thinking about how to do it for
resale I think is huge
um and the income Suite is like the
newest it's not new by any means but I
think particularly
through covet and post covid with
people's living situations changing so
much people have really seen the benefit
and having that option whether it's to
rent or to use as a home office so
anytime we can do that
um it's it's a huge selling point have
you seen any Trends after covid that
people are you know not just for the
income unit but like in their house like
are they making bigger bedrooms bigger
office spaces have you seen anything
like that especially implementing that
in your own Renovations I think just
having the ability to have a space that
is the office because I think um you
know it can be romanticized working from
home but if you don't have a space that
you're working from like we've moved
Steve around a million times he was
working in the garage and he was working
up here and trying to like identify this
space that works while you have kids
that are coming and going from school or
camp and all those kind of things like
it's not as easy as just sit popping out
on your couch and your PJs and working
so I think people looking for a home
like we need two bedrooms but we want a
three because we need this to be a
dedicated workspace base is definitely
something that is more asked when people
are looking for homes you know I think
it is also worth noting uh in this
Premiere episode it's probably just the
way that the episode was edited and
structured but there isn't a lot of mom
there's not a lot of Karen in this
episode and I feel like a lot of fans
are going to be asking like is this
indicative of like season eight so yeah
she's retired and she's been coming in
in and out but are we going to see a
little less of her this season I mean I
think it's a little bit of a it's just
the natural transition of the business
so whereas you know I would review floor
plans we'd go over those together I
don't do that
um and the design is much more me and
touching base with MJ so a lot of the
things that were the role that she
played when she was still an active part
of the company with her being retired
now she doesn't she doesn't deal with
those things
um she does the things that she really
loves doing and that is landscaping and
then like her projects so that is where
she shines and those aren't work for her
so those make sense to keep doing
whereas dealing with taxes or going back
and forth 10 times on the floor plans or
dealing with materials getting lost like
that's not fun
um and that's what she retired from she
kept the fun stuff the stressful stuff
but you handle it so very very well I
know there's always like I think there
was like a situation with the house
literally leaning on like it's always
that case like I think it's like in
every episode like in Indiana home it's
always living on one brick so yes yeah
that we always have these magic floating
houses and I don't know how they've it
the thing is they don't crumble until
you poke them like they will stay
magical forever you start to move one
brick to fix it and then you're fixing
the whole thing that's so crazy um you
know I I do know that you've been really
candid about your relationship with your
mom and I'm wondering um you know with
the show being in its eighth season now
does something like this bring you guys
closer or does it create more challenges
you know it's so we if I know you listen
to my podcast
um so I talk a little bit more about it
there but my mom and I have had an up
and down relationship since I was a
small child and we've had moments where
we were probably dysfunctionally close
and then moments where we didn't speak
for years and the start of the show was
in one of those times where we were
really really close we were like each
other's number one we were doing this
together and as we've gotten older and
she got married and I got married and
I've had kids like so many things have
happened since the show started she
retired it is it's really hard to
maintain like a good balance when you
don't really have a great base like we
do particularly in the microscope of the
show because it just creates so many
more Dynamics so it's definitely been a
struggle and that was part of why she
retired is you know I'm trying to build
an Empire she wants to slow down and
until we got on the same page with that
and what that looked like it it was
tough because I'm like why are you going
so slow and she's like because I'm old
and I want to hang out and chill and you
know making the decision to to do the
buyout for her I think helped a lot but
there's still just it's it's tough when
you're you're working with family all
the time
um and we don't really have time because
we're filming so much to kind of go to
our corners and then come back so you
don't have that like you know debrief
moment where you can talk yourself
through okay this is what happened this
is reasonable it's just go go so when we
get a break we kind of all go to our
corners and we're like we maybe all
we're kind of butt heads let's let's
figure out how we move forward from this
I will commend you about this but um
being a woman in construction is one of
those things it's like it breaks
normative tradition and and I'm actually
really happy to see HGTV leads the way
on like women-led construction shows a
lot of renovation shows
um I want to know like what what have
you learned about yourself in overcoming
what I imagine is obstacles and implicit
gender bias in the field that is so
prominent I mean unfortunately it's just
getting older and caring less because it
doesn't go away you're not going to
change people because they don't even
know that they need to change a lot of
them don't even know they're doing it
um and when you're younger everything's
such a big deal and you just care so
much about everything and then you know
get married have kids people die like
all these things that create more
balance in your life of what's really
important and knowing that okay I don't
need you to understand me I need you to
do what I'm telling you to do and being
okay with that is definitely something
for me that came with age
um and okay yeah if you want to think
I'm the b word instead of just being
Direct that's on you do the thing that I
paid you to do
um
that's just kind of how I deal with it
yeah because I I can imagine it's a lot
like you know you see even like when
we're just driving down the streets like
construction workers are outside you see
also people building homes it's men and
then it looks like you know this is a
fantasy like what you're doing but it's
actually a reality like we can see you
building homes you have your own
construction company and you're leading
charge on those things and I just think
that's great like we don't see a lot I
mean if if anyone did not watch Risky
Business watch that because you can't
make this Loop up I got so many messages
that had been fake like you guys edited
that and made it worse I'm like no no we
edited it to make it better because it
was that bad like the level of Challenge
and misogyny in that project was born on
the worst I've ever experienced so
it can be a challenge yeah and speaking
of challenges I know social media is one
of them I know that you get a lot of
keyboard Warriors
um but you're so smart at navigating and
like creating boundaries and stuff but
um you know sometimes they will overstep
and I know that one of them I think last
week I think you had to block or was a
couple of days ago but they deserved it
so
um yeah how do you how do you deal with
that especially since you are getting
you know bigger on social media there's
a lot more followers now and you're
becoming a prominent figure you know I
think again when I was younger like
you're counting those likes and then
when the show starts you're like how
many people loved it how many people
said they hated it all those things
where everyone else is like their
outside opinions
holds so much weight and I would never
block anyone because then I would lose a
follower and like you want the most
amount of followers like when I broke
600 000 I was like oh my
um I've lost like 4 000 followers in the
last week it goes up and down it's so
Random I don't know the algorithm but I
got to the point where I was like this
isn't like you clearly don't want me in
your life I annoy you I upset you I
whatever and I don't need you in mind so
let's just not and it was very
liberating to change my mind and be like
if you can't be here and be a normal
human then you don't get to be here and
that's fine and if that matters that
means I drop under 600 000 followers
it's probably better because those
people are following me because they're
actually interested in what I have to
say and not following me because it's
the trainer act that they're following
and they're hate following it or
whatever it is
um but again something that is like new
to uh that I'm am I aging into I don't
know if I'm aging into it gracefully but
I'm doing it
doing great I mean a lot of times I feel
like a lot lot of fans they think you're
just the one thing but you are also a
mom you're somebody who has interest you
love Taylor Swift like me like there's a
lot of things that you are more than
just you know this one job so I feel
like you know it's you're doing a great
job navigating it and like who cares
about the haters they're haters for a
reason that was a big reason I wanted to
do the podcast is because while the show
is 100 all of who we are
um it is it is a small part because it's
42 minutes of such a big amount of time
and it's been really interesting to see
that kind of change over to people that
follow me versus who are converted as
listeners because it's upsetting to some
people because this the HGTV what
they're so good at is telling this
amazing story there should be ups and
downs it's gonna be a roller coaster but
it's going to end happy and you're gonna
have a beautiful reveal and that
actually happened and a lot of other
things happened that aren't tied up in a
pretty bow and like I was I was saying
um in a previous interview like I
watched the Kardashians because it it's
kind of mindless and it makes me I feel
like my life's not so crazy so if they
all of a sudden changed and like weren't
being a disaster I'd be like I don't
want to watch this anymore
well interesting seeing the the
different people who are drawn to the
different
um available content that they can
consume um you know I love that um but
but you know before I let you go I know
you've worked on more than like 100
homes since your first uh since you
first started the business in 2014 2015
well first house was 2007 and the
business was established in 2009. the
pilot was 2014. right okay so I'm
wondering if there's anything about
these Renovations that still continues
to surprise you I mean the magic
floating houses uh every time I know it
probably seems like oh they've seen this
a million times it is still always
shocking how some of these houses are
standing
um and just
I know so much I've had so many
experiences in this construction world
and that I still have the ability to
really screw things up or have a
contractor Royal and like we've done
this why are we doing it again did we
not learn from the last thing so the
ability for things to go awry is still
shocking with how much experience
yeah it's a little bit maybe but I mean
like there's so much that you've learned
and I think that's something to be
really proud about and it's something
like you you know set an example for
other women I know that's not something
that you intend to do but there are a
lot of women I know that look up to you
also so that's something that you should
be so proud about
um but I I'm so happy to talk to you I
always love talking to you Mina thank
you so much for your time today I'm so
excited for season 8 of good bones it
premieres August 15th and it will stream
uh the same day on Max and it'll be on
HGTV of course but Mina thanks so much
you have a good one thank you I always
love talking to you